A mysterious pneumonia outbreak in Wuhan, China
A new type of coronavirus
The number of affected countries
has tripled.
The world health organization
has just declared
that this is a pandemic.
(Clapping)
The city all essential workers
who are showing up every day.
It's still March.
And the Oscar goes to
Parasite.
Shhhh.
Please, sit down.
Thank you.
I've never seen her before.
Hey, all you cool cats and kittens!
So "Folklore" is out.
Dodgers have won it all in 2020!
The Los Angeles Lakers
This is so much bigger than just us.
I always said talent is more
important than experience.
I've always said that.
Everybody right now is worried that TikTok's gonna be
banned in the United States.
Normal life cancelled.
Eleven days into the national lockdown...
All public gatherings banned.
Working from home is the new reality.
Are any of ya'll wearing pants?
Now, be honest now.
School is closed
...for the remainder of the academic year.
Guys, what happened?
It kicked her off the internet.
Yup, we're toast.
I see Brandon is holding up two
and two - I see four ...
More than four hundred children million children ...
Zoom after zoom can be exhausting.
It seems like the world's caving in on you.
Yeah.
Work never stops.
It could be taking a toll on your well-being.
Italy saw it's deadliest day from the coronavirus
as the death toll jumped by more than 600 in 24 hours.
The plan we have is to contain
- contain the disease outbreak in Taiwan.
We have very little problem in this country at this moment. Five
... people have contracted the virus.
Let us build up our confidence.
We will eventually win.
Many of all countries in Europe are now acting to
"flatten the curve" used when talking about
reducing the number of coronavirus cases.
Americans unemployment more than 3.3 million -
more than 6 million - I hope that's right.
10 million workers now applying for unemployment.
50 million unemployment claims filed
in the span of just four months.
A disproportionate number are black.
It's called systemic racism for a reason.
There's 400 years of history here.
What do we want?
Justice!
When do we want it?
Now!
One man's death has rekindled this movement around the world.
Say his name!
George Floyd!
Frustration over the lack of charges against the officers.
They should be charged.
There's always a better way.
Protestors kneeling and raising their hands in peaceful demonstration.
The poured onto the street.
"Resign," they shouted.
They are scared.
They fear they are losing the power.
The worst fire season ever and
every year builds on the last one it seems like.
Yeah, it really does.
This is everything we've worked for for the last 35 years - gone.
This looks more like mars.
One of the most busy hurricane seasons ever on record.
Devastation in Puerto Rico.
India and Pakistan are facing their
worst locust outbreak in 70 years.
Cases are up.
More than 30 states and Puerto Rico
reporting cases on the rise.
A possible "second wave"
-  going global.
60 million plus cases.
Almost 1.5 million deaths.
I've developed mild symptoms.
French President Emmanuel Macron,
President Bolsonaro,
Press Secretary Kayleigh McEnany,
Donald Trump
tested positive for the coronavirus.
I think it's under control. I'll tell you what -
How? A thousand Americans are dying a day.
They are dying.
That's true.
It is what it is.
We don't have enough stretchers.
We're way above capacity.
Cemeteries have become overwhelmed.
I think we could've been a little more preventative.
You know? As a whole.
As a country.
When I'm president we will be better prepared.
Respond better
and recover better.
Some lines stretching for blocks
forcing people to wait hours to cast their ballots.
It could have rained.
It could have snowed.
I would not care.
I'm not going anywhere.
Andrzej Duda has been reelected president of Poland.
Many Malawians already knew from early, unofficial results
that he would be their next president.
Tsai defeated a pro-Beijing rival.
Luis Arce promised he would rule for all.
We will be a party that governs for every New Zealander.
We did it, Joe.
The flame of democracy was lit in this nation a long time ago.
And we now know nothing -
not even a pandemic,
or an abuse of power
can extinguish that flame.
I hope I aren't gonna have the bloody bug now.
We press on for what is right,
for what is fair,
and for what is just.